♪ ♪
BIG TIME HOLLYWOOD CELEBS MAKING
A MOCKERY OF COVID ROLES WITH
THE SUPER BOWL, FROLICKING
AROUND THE BIG GAME MASK LIST
WITHOUT TEAR IN THE WORLD WHILE
STUDENTS IN THE SAME STATE ARE
FORCED TO COVER UP INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE OF THEIR CLASSROOMS.
THE NFL WARNING FANS BEFOREHAND
TO COMPLY WITH ALL L.A. COUNTY
HEALTH AND SAFETY PROTOCOLS.
MASKS WERE GIVEN OUT AT THE BIG
GAME, BUT FEW OF THE MORE THAN
70,000 FANS WERE SEEN WEARING
THEM.
REPEAT OFFENDER, LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI ONCE AGAIN
HOLDING HIS BREATH, ALLEGEDLY,
AFTER HE GOT CAUGHT MASKLESS YET
AGAIN IN THIS PHOTO.
IT ALL BEGS THE QUESTION, WHEN
WILL ALL DEMOCRATS FINALLY GIVE
UP ON MANDATES THAT THEIR
BIGGEST SUPPORTERS KEEP
BREAKING?
IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
PRESIDENT BIDEN WILL BE COMING
AROUND.
HE SAYS OPPOSING MASK MANDATES
ISN'T ABOUT FREEDOM.
>> MANY OF THOSE PEOPLE WON'T BE
WEARING MASKS DESPITE THE LOCAL
LAW IN LOS ANGELES.
WHAT IS YOUR MESSAGE TO PEOPLE
WHO WANT DESPERATELY FOR THIS TO
BE OVER AND TO BE ABLE TO RESUME
THE LIVES THAT THEY REMEMBER?
>> President Biden: WELL,
LOOK.
I LOVE ALL PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
PERSONAL FREEDOM.
IF YOU'RE EXERCISING PERSONAL
FREEDOM PUTS SOMEONE ELSE IN
JEOPARDY, THEIR HEALTH IN
JEOPARDY, I DON'T CONSIDER THAT
BEING VERY FREEDOM.
>> ON WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU TRY
ASKING DEMOCRATS WHERE THEY
ACTUALLY STAND ON THE ISSUE?
>> I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU THAT I
HAD A VERY HARD TIME GETTING
STRAIGHT ANSWERS OUT OF
DEMOCRATS ON THE HILL THIS WEEK
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT THEY
THOUGHT IT WAS TIME TO LIFT MASK
MANDATES BECAUSE IN PART THEY
ARE LISTENING TO THEIR
GOVERNORS, IN PART THEY ARE
LISTENING TO THEIR CONSTITUENTS,
IN PART THEY'RE LOOKING OVER
THEIR SHOULDER AS TO WHETHER
THEY HAVE A REELECTION OR NOT.
SO MANY OF THEM WERE LIKE WE
SHOULD FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
OKAY, WELL YOUR GOVERNOR IS
SAYING ONE THING, THE PRESIDENT
AND CDC ARE SAYING ANOTHER,
WHICH ONE DO YOU THINK IS THE
SCIENCE?
VERY HARD TO NAIL PEOPLE DOWN ON
THE QUESTION.
>> OKAY, SO I WILL START WITH
YOU, DANA.
>> OKAY.
>> WHICH IS THE SCIENCE?
>> IF THEY WERE CALLING THE
SIGNS THE KIDS WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE FIRST ONES TO NOT HAVE TO
WEAR MASKS AND UNFORTUNATELY,
THE KIDS ARE BASICALLY AT THE
MERCY OF THE TEACHERS UNIONS,
WHICH SEEMS TO MAKE NO SENSE TO
ME.
I ALSO THINK IT'S GOOD NEWS THAT
78,000 PEOPLE WENT TO THE
SUPER BOWL AND IGNORED THE MASK
MANDATE, WHICH BASICALLY MEANS
EVERYBODY ELSE CAN TOO EXCEPT
FOR THE KIDS, BUT THAT'S WHEN
THE ABSURDITIES WILL TURN INTO
OUTRAGES AND ALSO I THINK ABOUT
ERIC GARCETTI, WHO HAD THE NERVE
TO SAY WHAT HE SAID ABOUT WELL I
DIDN'T INHALE.
>> I HELD MY BREATH.
AND HE SAYS DOES THAT MAKE YOU
HAPPY YOU MAKE AND BASICALLY
THESE PEOPLE THAT ARE IN CHARGE
OF THESE CITIES, THEY DON'T CARE
ABOUT THE CITIZENS.
THEY THINK THEY ARE STUPID.
THEY DON'T CARE AT ALL ABOUT
THEM AND THEY GET TO GO TO THE
SUPER BOWL, GOT A FREE TICKET
I'M SURE BECAUSE HE'S THE MAYOR,
AND EVER BUT ALSO SITTING THERE
GOING BUT MY KIDS STILL HAS TO
WEAR A MASK AND ANY MINUTE NOW
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE ALL THESE
REPORTERS, THEY ARE GOING TO
START TO WRITE ANOTHER ROUND OF
ARTICLES ABOUT THEY ARE SO
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LACK OF
TRUST IN INSTITUTIONS IN
AMERICA, AND THEN THEY DON'T
HAVE THE NERVE TO LOOK AT
THEMSELVES IN THE MIRROR.
>> SO JESSE, DO THEY REALLY
THINK THAT WE ARE STUPID?
>> YES AND NO BECAUSE AS A
CELEBRITY YOU HAVE TO BE SEEN,
AND YOU UNDERSTAND THAT.
IT'S ACTUALLY MORE UNHEALTHY TO
NOT BE RECOGNIZED WHEN YOU'RE A
CELEBRITY THEN TO CATCH COVID
WHEN YOU'RE IS LIBERTY, AND THAT
IS A MEDICAL FACT.
HOW ARE PEOPLE GOING TO KNOW
THAT AFFLECK AND JENNIFER LOPEZ
ARE AT THE SUPER BOWL IF THEY'RE
WEARING MASKS?
THE POINT IS TO BE SEEN, AND WHY
HAVEN'T FAUCI AND BIDEN COME OUT
TODAY AND SHAMED ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE?
100 MILLION PEOPLE WATCHING,
FLOUTING HIS RULES.
THESE GUIDELINES ARE HERE TO
SAVE LIVES AND TO DO THAT SENDS
A WRONG MESSAGE.
I'M SHOCKED FAUCI IS NOT ON
EVERY SINGLE PROGRAM SHAMING
THESE PEOPLE.
I THINK ACTUALLY WHAT HAPPENED
IS WHEN THE PEOPLE IN
LOS ANGELES SAW MAGIC JOHNSON,
WHO HAS AIDS, A PRETTY SERIOUS
COMORBIDITY, NOT CARE AND NOT
WEAR A MASK YOU, I THINK PEOPLE
FIGURED MAYBE THEY DIDN'T NEED
TO WEAR ONE ALSO.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO WATCH
CHILDREN HOST A TV SHOW.
IMAGINE IF KIDS HAVE THEIR OWN
TV SHOWS.
THERE WOULD BE A LOT OF BANGING
ON DESKS TODAY.
A LOT OF "DO AS I SAY, NOT AS I
DO" KIND OF STUFF BECAUSE YOU
HAVE 70,000 PEOPLE SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER SCREAMING INSIDE AND
THEN YOU CAN'T HAVE 12 CHILDREN
INSIDE WITHOUT A MASK ON?
IT MAKES NO SENSE.
IF THE ONLY REASON KIDS STILL
HAVE TO WEAR MASKS IS THEY DON'T
HAVE LAWYERS AND TV SHOWS.
IF THEY DID, OBVIOUSLY THIS
WOULDN'T HAPPEN.
I HAVE A NEW THING WHAT I DO
WITH MASKS.
I DON'T CARRY ONE OUT.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY HERE DOES
BUT WHEN YOU DON'T CARRY ONE OUT
AND YOU GO INTO A STORE THEY
HASSLE YOU AND YOU SAY I DON'T
HAVE ONE, SORRY AND THEY EITHER
SLINK AWAY OR THEY GIVE YOU A
FREE MASK, SO THEN YOU PUT THE
FREE MASK ON AND AS YOU LEAVE
YOU JUST TAKE IT OFF AND YOU
DROP IT IN THE WASTEBASKET AND
YOU WALK OUT.
AND THAT'S KIND OF THE DASH A
PASSIVE-AGGRESSIVE WAY FOR ME TO
FIGHT THE MAN.
>> THAT'S REALLY WELL THOUGHT
OUT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
>> HAROLD, WHAT ABOUT THE FACT
THAT BIDEN SAYS IF YOU DON'T
WEAR A MASK IT'S NOT A MATTER OF
YOUR PERSONAL FREEDOM?
>> I THINK IN FAIRNESS, WHAT HE
SAID IS YOUR PERSONAL FREEDOM,
IF IT INFRINGES ON SOMEONE
ELSE'S HEALTH OR FREEDOM -- BUT
YOUR LARGER POINT I GUESS.
I THINK THAT DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS, THE COUNTRY ALIKE,
IS COMING TO GRIPS WITH THE FACT
THAT WE HAVE MADE GREAT, GREAT
STRIDES AGAINST THIS VIRUS.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE NUMBERS.
80% MORE HAVE ONE DOES, 65% OR
MORE OR TWO'S, 43% OF ELIGIBLE
PEOPLE ARE BOOSTED.
A YEAR AGO I WASN'T VACCINATED.
I THINK -- DIDN'T GET FULLY
VACCINATED UNTIL THE BEGINNING
OF APRIL, SO THE CONVERSATION
TODAY VERSUS A YEAR AGO IS FAR
DIFFERENT AND NOW POLITICIANS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS ARE
REALLY -- NOT DOING -- AS MUCH
IS TRYING TO RECONCILE THINGS.
WE'VE SET ON THIS SHOW BEFORE,
GREG, YOU SAID IT A FEW WEEKS
AGO, BUT IT WILL EVENTUALLY BE
THE PEOPLE WHO WILL PUSH THE
POLITICIANS AND PUSH OUR HEALTH
EXPERTS TO TELL US WHEN AND
WHERE -- I SHOULD SAY GO FASTER
IN HOW THEY ARE DOING THINGS.
MY KIDS -- MY KIDS ARE NO
VACCINATED, I HAVE A SIX YEAR
OLD AND AN 8-YEAR-OLD.
I FEEL FAR MORE COMFORTABLE
GOING OUT, BEING OUT, BEING
SOCIAL, KNOWING THAT IF I DO GO
HOME, IF I TRANSMIT SOMETHING,
MY KIDS ARE LIKELY NOT GOING TO
BE HOSPITALIZED.
BUT 12 STATES, BLUE STATES,
LOOSENING THESE MANDATES AND
RESTRICTIONS, I THINK IT'S A
POSITIVE THING AND I THINK
EVERYBODY SHOULD TAKE A VICTORY
LAP, PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
PRESIDENT BIDEN.
>> DE PLANTA GETTING YOUR KIDS
THE VACCINE?
>> THEY ARTY HAVE IT, THEY'VE
BEEN VACCINATED SINCE EARLY
DECEMBER.
I DIDN'T HESITATE AT ALL.
>> INTERESTING.
ALL RIGHT, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
WRAP IT UP?
>> I WOULD LOVE TO WRAP IT UP.
>> ON VALENTINES.
>> DID YOU GET MY GIFT?
>> I'M AFRAID.
>> I FORGOT TO PUT HOLES IN IT.
>> THAT'S MEAN.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT MEANS.
WE KEEP COMPLAINING ABOUT
HYPOCRISY, I THINK WE HAVE TO
ADMIT THAT TALK BUT HYPOCRISIES
TALK ABOUT OXYGEN.
IT'S NEVER GOING TO GO AWAY SO
IT'S ALMOST POINTLESS.
THE OTHER THING IS, IT IS
ABOUT -- WHO ARE YOU TO ALLOW
WHO SAYS WHAT IS INFRINGING
VERSUS NOT INFRINGING.
THE MOMENT YOU GET INTO A CAR
THERE'S A POTENTIAL OF
INFRINGING A PEDESTRIAN'S RIGHTS
RIGHT?
BUT YOU STILL GET INTO A CAR.
YOU SEE THE PRESIDENT AND THE
MEDIA REDEFINING THE IDEA OF
FREEDOM THAT IN A WEIRD WAY WHEN
SO MANY TALKS ABOUT FREEDOM, FOR
EXAMPLE THE TRUCKERS, IT IS
SOMETHING LIKE A DOG WHISTLE FOR
ANTI-VAXXERS OR EVEN FASCISM
COME UP BE VERY WARY OF ANYBODY
WHO TALKS TOO MUCH ABOUT
FREEDOM, WHICH IS BIZARRE COMING
FROM AN AMERICAN PRESIDENT.
WE ARE ALL ABOUT FREEDOM.
WE ARE ALSO SEEING A NEW KIND OF
VIRTUE SIGNALING HERE, WHICH IS
"I CAN DO WHAT I PLEASE AS LONG
AS WE TELL -- I TELL THE
CHILDREN TO MASK UP.
"EVERY GOVERNOR IN EVERY MAYOR
IN EVERY LITTLE SIRI HAS BEEN
DOING THIS.
IT'S NOT FAMOUS ACTRESSES WHO
HAVE REALLY BAD REPETITIONS, BUT
I CARE ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE SO I
CAN STILL BE AN ABSOLUTE JERK.
SO WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS KIND OF
AN INSISTENCE OF MASKING UP KIDS
TO ASSUAGE THEIR OWN GUILT.
THEY'RE BASICALLY JUST
ENCOURAGING CHILD ABUSE SO THEY
CAN CONTINUE HAVING A GOOD TIME.
SO I DON'T KNOW.
I THINK WE LIVE IN A TWO CLASS
SYSTEM.
BY THE WAY, WE CALLED THIS.
AGAIN, IT WAS ANOTHER LIGHT
PROTECTOR.
WE SET THE SUPER BOWL, THIS WAS
GOING TO HAPPEN, SO IT WAS JUST
DECLARE IT OVER BEFORE IT
HAPPENS, WE HAVE A TWO CLASS
SYSTEM, THE ONE THAT WANTS TO DO
WHAT IT WANTS AND THE ONE THAT
WANTS TO TELL YOU WHAT TO DO
WHILE THEY DO WHAT THEY WANT, WE
HAVE TO CRUSH THAT.
WE CAN'T HAVE PEOPLE TELLING US
WHAT WE CAN DO TO OUR KIDS
BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE IT'S
INFRINGING ON THEIR LIVES.
THAT IS A SLIPPERY SLOPE BUT
JUST GO STRAIGHT INTO SOMETHING
REALLY BAD.
>> YOU WOULD THINK THAT THE
BURDEN -- YOU WOULD THINK THAT
THE BURDEN IS ON THE PERSON, YOU
KNOW, WHO HAS MORE TO LOSE AT
THAT POINT, BUT THEY DON'T WANT
TO DO THAT.
>> THEY GAVE 78,000K95 MASKS
AWAY FOR NOTHING.
COULD HAVE GONE TO ACTUAL
NURSES, FIRST RESPONDERS TH